يتعين على جميع الشركات ،
وجميع مالكي ومشغلي البنية التحتية الحيوية ،
أن يفترضوا أن
النشاط السيبراني التخريبي
هو
شيء
يفكر فيه الروس ويستعدون لذلك ،
ويستكشفون الخيارات كما قال الرئيس
، وأنهم يجب أن يعتبروا أنفسهم
معرضين للخطر ومعرضين للخطر ،
ولكن هذا
هو مصدر قلقك الآن  أن النية
موجودة
لأن الروس يشعرون
بضغوط العقوبات هو أن ما يجعل
هذه اللحظة مختلفة
أعتقد أن ما يجعل اللحظة مختلفة
هو مجرد رؤية ما فعله الروس
بهذا الغزو غير
المبرر لأوكرانيا ومن ثم فهم أنه
يمكن أن يكون هناك بعض
عواقب حقيقية جدًا لذلك في الفضاء الإلكتروني
خاصةً لأن النشاط السيبراني الضار
هو جزء من قواعد اللعبة الروسية
، وبالتالي قد تكون هناك
عواقب متتالية غير مقصودة من
الهجمات الإلكترونية الروسية في أوكرانيا في
أوروبا قد يكون هناك زيادة في
نشاط برامج الفدية وقد تكون هناك
هجمات انتقامية متعمدة
لشدة جدا
عقوبات عقابية جمعت الولايات المتحدة وحلفاؤنا
معًا كمجتمع لفرضها على
روسيا وروسيا
وقد تشعر الحكومة الروسية أنها تستطيع استخدام
هذه القدرات في هذا
النشاط التحضيري في استكشاف
الهجمات السيبرانية المحتملة
ليكون لها تأثير حقيقي على الولايات المتحدة
اشخاص